hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and it is sunny this is Tamra Jessa and
last night
I saw the fourth insidious what is it
insidious chapter 4 insidious we're
doing this again insidious the last key
I watched all three of the first
insidious movies the day before and kind
of got caught up I haven't seen any of
them I always told people that I had
seen the first but that was made up I
thought that I had I had not so I want
all of them and I was honestly pretty
impressed they have high budgets the
storyline is good not stellar but like
good I think they made a fatal flaw in
the first one by killing off the main
character spoilers I guess if you're
watching this I assume you've seen the
first or don't care and I guess I'll say
spoilers for the last key as well though
nothing really happens that's crazy
shocking there's one twist I'll say and
I won't bring that up in the review so
kind of spoilers I if you don't know
love horror films and I really really
love high budgets well-made horror films
weird she doesn't like low-budget
horror films actually I do like those as
well but I'm a big fan of the conjuring
series and the Annabelle series and I
just really enjoy when a horror film
gets backing and gets a good budget and
is well made and and this is what these
are they hi
I want to say I wish that the stories
were a little more fleshed out and I
wish that there's a there's a couple
things that happens it's like okay well
we're seeing this a million bazillion
times but for the most part they're just
fun well-made scary films and I would
recommend them if you haven't seen them
if you like horror I made a video for my
personal channel talking about the first
three so right now I'm just gonna talk
about this latest installment the last
key first and foremost
new previews for this movie all looked
amazing I want to see every single
preview which it doesn't mean anything
about the film that you're about to see
but in my mind it's always a good omen
I'm just gonna go through them real
quick truth or dare looks stupid and fun
Pacific Rim - I've not seen one so I
guess I should do that the New Mutants
looks amazing proud Mary yes the
Winchester house movie yes game night
amazing have you seen the previous one
that looks so good
Midnight Sun really stupid-looking
romantic chick flick and I can't wait to
see it okay I'm getting into the actual
film why you clicked on this video lin
shaye plays Elise trainer and she
started off in the first film and
through some events head over here and
the timelines are all screwed up because
they killed off her character in the
very first movie which is a big mistake
because she's like the standout star of
the film and she's clearly the star in
this one and so this takes place right
before the first film takes place
timeline wise it also takes place in her
childhood and kind of gives you a little
bit of backstory there and it's really
nice to see that I will say though I do
think they made a mistake in killing her
off people might say it was like a like
a stylistic choice or like oh like a fun
thing so they could do all this timeline
stuff I feel like it was a mistake and
then they were like I will just do weird
timeline things but they've really made
the timeline jumps work like the second
film was in between it like it all
matches up very nicely and they have
tied it in really well if it was a
choice what an odd one but it works
Elise is such an interesting character
in that I would never have cast her as
this role and I would have never said
that a four movie arc horror story could
be led by this woman who really gives me
a vibe of like this cool aunt who smokes
weed all the time she's just super chill
like kind of earthy that's the vibe that
I get from the character of Elise they
really do a good job of showing you that
she's just a human that has the
like people who have these abilities
don't need to be like witchy and like
trendy with crystals even though I watch
that maybe as well at least is just
she's a cool she's a cool aunt she
literally is a cool aunt as you see in
this film she does have a few things
that she does over and over always in
the film somebody's like can you do this
and she's like I can't do it because of
these personal deep-rooted issues and
then two seconds later she's like I have
to do it and then she does it so that
happens and almost maybe not the first
but definitely two three ends in the
last game and it's like we all know
you're gonna do it at least you have a
heart of gold girl you're gonna do it
and then she doesn't Elise has paired up
with these two guys specs and the creepy
one Tucker I don't love them as her
sidekicks one of them is a sound guy one
of them writes down things I don't think
I again I feel like they were a mistake
they came along in the first film and
they were supposed to be this comedic
duo to kind of lighten the mood and and
this I do think they achieved some
comedy though some of it was awkward in
the other films I don't think that the
comedy was achieved well at all and
they're just not there like right there
like knockoff brand comedy duo and he
just doesn't really work for me I don't
love them but I do love their shirts and
I want one put that out into the
universe so the film takes place over
two different timelines
it starts off and it shows you a little
bit of Elise's backstory and kind of
developing her powers and a diamond that
has plagued her her whole life it also
shows Elise as an adult and it takes
place when she's an adult right before
the first movie takes place there's also
a couple plots happening in this film
the first is helping this guy get the
demon out of her childhood home he's now
living there so she goes and she does
that and then that's resolved kind of
and then another whole thing takes place
and there's kind of a lot happening it
feels kind of like this could have been
two really cool Netflix specials
now I compare everything to Netflix
that's where we are in film now there's
a point in the movie where one of the
Lisa's nieces there's a point in the
movie where one of Elise's nieces
reveals that she can see things too and
that's exactly the line that comes out
she's like I can see things too and
someone behind me goes whoa look really
dramatically and breathed in and it was
a really nice really nice moment can't
imagine seeing this while the story made
sense the the main key bad guy demon
demons are bad guys if you didn't know
well the main bad guy made sense because
it went into her past and now she's
revisiting it revisiting it it it also
has a sense of kind of just being backed
into a corner it feels like the fourth
of a horror franchise honestly and ace
well done it is well done and there were
some genuine scares I set up fronts cuz
the whole back of the theater was full
and no one was in the front three row
section and I was just the thing they're
like in glee because there is a really
really really good scares ads they
really kept the suspense up it did in
moments so feel like they backed
themselves into a corner again by
killing her off in the first one I'd
really like to see more of this really
cool chill aunt who smokes weed I don't
imagine they're going to take this any
further after this one it doesn't feel
resolved so it's just a bit like why why
why did you make that choice and it's a
shame that that is impacting this film
one of the biggest problems with this is
that you know she's going to die in the
first film which takes place right after
this timeline wise and so you know she's
not gonna die
so you're watching it and even though
things are happening to her there's no
suspense for her safety you know she's
gonna make it
honestly it was a really good horror
film it it had moments of scariness at
the end I was really touched with the
storyline the acting is honestly really
good for a horror film for a fourth
installment of a horror film really nice
really well done I just it the one
problem I have with it is that they
killed off at least in the first film
and it's still bothering me now in the
fourth I don't imagine they're planning
on doing another one and that's another
problem I have is that it just doesn't
feel wrapped up because I really have
come to really enjoy this character let
me know what your favorite of the four
are I really enjoyed one and three and
four two is okay
also check out my personal channel I
posted a video talking about the first
three and I would love to hear your
thoughts there as well thank you so much
for watching I'll see you all next week
pork
you